sara is with us in Denver hi Sara
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
it's an honor to speak with you today
you too what's up in your world my
husband and I are debt-free we have our
emergency funds and we're on baby step
four we have been saving for a home but
we are to buy a home we don't own yet
but we're not sure we want to buy in the
town that we live and we want to know is
it insanity to buy an RV and work and
travel or a year or so until we figure
out where we want to be no long as you
pay cash for it yep that's our plan okay
and and I would recommend you buy a
fairly used one because our V's go down
in value like crazy exactly we are
looking at used and we are going to
follow the rule of no more than 50% of
our income what would you pay for it
we're looking at around 20,000 okay all
right that's cool because you know RVs
go up to 350 right or more right I
didn't know what you're talking about
cuz I don't want you to turn 350 into
175 in one year that would not be a plan
okay and you could do that pretty easy
with this game but if you're gonna buy
20 it's not gonna go down much in a year
it's uh you know that what that thing so
for new probably eighty yeah so it's
already lost most of its value and as
long as it's mechanically reliable and
reasonably comfortable for your purposes
for this 1-year adventure or so that
you're going on it sounds fun is this
something both of you want to do you're
both excited about yes yes my husband
travels full time for work and we've
always kind of dreamed about me quitting
my full-time job and getting to go with
him on the road
yeah cool there's anything you can do
while you're traveling just
we generate some income - I sure hope so
I am the cleanest side hustle I always
have a side hustle that's cool
that's gonna be if you have children at
home we do not have children okay well
that makes it real easy right so well
that's the idea yeah yeah I like it I I
mean it's a lot of people's dream to do
that at retirement and so it's a cool
thing to do it now while you can and
just enjoy the ride and and and the
thing is it's not a decision you're
making the decision in terms of the
twenty thousand dollar range of RV so
wisely that it's not a decision that you
have to strain to undo when you get
ready to put down roots and you want to
settle somewhere boom or you decided we
love it and we're gonna upgrade an RV
and do this for five years and but we
want them a little nicer that's okay
you're gonna be able to do it all right
yeah that sounds great yeah and we had
miss Dorothy ran melissa's that mr.
Melissa's in the in Martha's place in
our kitchen here now that makes Omega
keys and everything everyday but right
before her was a lady named Dorothy and
Dorothy and her husband retired and
that's what they do they travel an RV
full-time then and they go they live two
months in place two months another place
and just to travel to see the nation
that was just their goal at retirement
and they bought a really nice one you
know but they had tons of money they've
been doing financial piece for years and
they've just done a great job and that
they're there to live in the dream you
know so I love it yeah I'd do it the
only reason I wouldn't do it is if you
bought something super expensive that
you lost a ton of money during this year
and and that would make the adventure
less than fun but this sounds like a
great adventure go do it